thank you very much for joining us we
begin with breaking news
out of lebanon's capital beirut and a
massive fire has broken out at the site
of last month's deadly port
explosion these are live pictures
firefighters are
battling the blaze at a destroyed
warehouse let's go straight to
al jazeera's zener hodder in beirut
force
these images are quite impressive xena
what's happened and what's caused this
fire
well a massive fire like you mentioned
raging at the
of course destroyed beirut port just
five weeks ago a massive explosion
destroyed that port you can see right
behind me the lebanese army
issuing a statement just a short while
ago saying that a warehouse
where oils and tires were stored
caught fire now what we also understand
from the lebanese red cross
is that this was not a deliberate fire
because a few days
ago there was a smaller fire at beirut
port
and that fire was reportedly caused
it was it was deliberate so this time
around they're saying that this
was not a deliberate fire as you can
imagine it caused
panic and chaos in the streets of of the
capital you can see we are
close to a main highway the main highway
that links north lebanon
this is the entrance to beirut the
northern entrance to beirut
it is empty people took it upon
themselves to evacuate
uh to evacuate the area and the director
general of the beirut port
telling local media just now that the
fire
occurred at the uh the free excuse me
the free market area the yes the beirut
free market
area of the port and that uh cooking oil
spread to the rubber tires so cooking
oil spread to the rubber tires that was
stored at this warehouse in beirut
port um so you know i can i can just
tell you when
when the people of beirut saw this fire
everybody it brought back
back memories right a lot of people have
been traumatized you can see how much
smoke
there is indeed indeed uh
the pictures are quite impressive these
are live pictures from beirut
the skies of beirut clouded
in black smoke this thursday
over a month after the deadly explosion
at the porch there's a fire now burning
there
uh asana was just saying this is said to
be an accidental
uh fire by by the authorities as in as
you say people in lebanon i imagine
still traumatized by the august 4th
explosion and now seeing
this large plume of black smoke in the
skies once again in beirut must be
adding to their worries and concerns i
know there's an investigation
in going into the explosion of
august 4th that deadly explosion at the
port what is the latest on that
well the judge which is leading the
investigation
into the port explosion for the first
time
has started to question ministers now uh
the
caretaker prime minister who was in
power at the time of the explosion well
he
was questioned a few days ago so right
now what this investigative judge is
doing
is questioning witnesses listening to
their testimonies deciding whether or
not
they should be arrested already more
than 20 people
have been arrested in the ongoing
investigations but mainly the head of
beirut port the head of customs
it's mainly the port and customs
officials and this is not enough for
many lebanese many lebanese believe that
the senior officials
politicians as well as security
officials should be held to account
they should be behind bars because they
were repeatedly told
about the presence of dangerous and
highly explosive material
at warehouse 12 at beirut port and they
chose not to do anything
they blame them for the negligence they
blame them for not
caring about public safety because you
can see where the port is located it is
yes along along the sea but but there's
residential neighborhoods a hundred
thousand people
live within a kilometer radius of beirut
port
and that's why so many people lost their
lives
even the highway this is the main
highway that links northern
lebanon to to beirut many people were
killed while
you know watching the flames be because
before that massive explosion there was
a fire at bay report
and the authorities did not warn the
public to move away
they did not tell them that highly
explosive material was at the port and
that's why there was so much anger
they feel that it was a man-made
disaster and that uh
officials higher up should be should be
held to account
thank you zaina a man made disaster on
october the 4th but this fire
burning right now at the devastated
beirut port is said to have been
accidental by lebanese authorities the
images are quite impressive as you can
see
the fire was reportedly started
at a store of tires and was an accident
according to the authorities they say
that the army is using helicopters
to help extinguish this fire at the
destroyed beirut
port this is coming a little over a
month of course after that huge
explosion
which devastated the port and
surrounding areas and left 190 people
dead
and thousands homeless we'll continue to
keep a close eye on
the situation in beirut for you this
thursday and bring you the very latest
with our correspondent zena hodder who's
on the ground